the website deadline performed an
autopsy on late night comedy's run
under trump revealing the pathetic
bubble the entertainment industry lives
in
one showrunner said after trump we
deserve to have some
frivolity as if they didn't have enough
that's like chris cuomo
saying he needs a bigger ego yet to them
riding anti-trump yucks is as grueling
as fighting fires or terrorists
what small people with huge blind spots
before kovid we had the strongest
economy in modern history
after kovid were coming back but we also
had no new wars and peace was breaking
out all over
which leftists like colbert or others
should applaud
but they couldn't because the emotional
trauma they experienced
from a trump personality mattered more
than the real world benefits of trump's
actual accomplishments
who cares if young adults didn't die in
combat or if household income rose by
the thousands or if everyone got a job
trump's kept noah awake all night
another writer moaned that post-trump
she's looking forward to a diversity of
thought
which means two thoughts i hate trump
and i really miss hating trump
i guess there weren't other things to
laugh at
why aren't i 50 points ahead you might
ask what do the facts say
the facts suggest that you absolutely
have a native american ancestor in your
pedigree
we choose truth over facts this is
something you can get
through the mail chocolate and then we
have some other chocolate here
this guy kilimnik keeps turning up again
and again constantine columbine
constantine kilimanik and constantine
kalimnik
this was the actual swab that was
being used no humor to be found there
hell my producer put that together in
minutes
what four teams of late night producers
couldn't do
in four years but i guess those targets
hit too close to home
and their paychecks so these elitist
whiners who despise the president
that put fewer body bags at our doorstep
and more cash in your wallet
are now relieved they need frivolity not
because they experienced any harm trump
did to the country
trump put an owie on their psyches and
that's the biggest joke of all
so i'm excited dana president obama is
going to be on kimmel this week
i wonder who's going to get the rose
[Laughter]
or what he'll reveal i i think it's
pretty interesting the
barack obama book i'm surprised it's
created no buzz
nothing like there's no big news stories
out of it there are no big republicans
excuse me topic dana we're bashing
late-night comments oh okay
um well i wanted to point out that
apparently even the far left is really
disappointed
in the what's his name jim carrey um
characterization of abiding or
impersonation they say it's not funny
yeah because they said like it's just
hero worship and they're bored by it
yeah um jesse uh i love how they pretend
there was nothing else to poke fun of
you know well i mean trump was pretty
funny greg he tried to buy greenland
yes i mean he bought the club he bought
the clemson football team 5 000
worth of fast food i mean he met with
kim jong-un twice
i mean the guy was a content machine but
it wasn't just that he brought a whole
cast of characters
right remember the mooch yes you had
kellyanne you had sarah sanders coming
in you had melania
you had a whole team of people who's
biden bringing in hunter
they won't even go there yes i mean you
can make some funny jokes about kamala
kind of conniving in the background
it's not that funny i think trump made
late night comedy great again but
the five still beats all those guys in
the ratings of course and we don't even
have writers no
imagine how funny i would be if i had a
writer
i mean i might have to look into that
all right so juan um they are looking
forward to diversity
um aren't they responsible for the lack
of diversity
in the first place well i think if you
clearly
making fun of trump there's not much
diversity in trump's
world but anyway i do think the big
problem here is that biden
comes across to me at least as a normal
guy i mean that you can
he's on the amtrak train in the night uh
he's a guy you were talking about big
politicians that was
20 years ago no that's not 20 i've seen
him on the train this year so i mean
i rode the amtrak with him last year so
i mean i got a selfie with him he was
shocked he wanted to get away from me as
fast as he could
i read one but you were talking about
you know big time politicians who use
their influence but
his son went to war went to afghanistan
right i mean he suffered loss in his
life so
i think the problem is he's boring that
he's normal he's like a normal guy and
for a comedian normal
is not funny what jesse just laid out
was a lot of stuff that you could make
fun of
even if you were a trump fan so that's
the problem is that joe biden is so
normal that you can't possibly make fun
of him there's
nothing there kennedy to make fun of
you know what the funniest presidential
impression was probably in the history
of snl
other than daryl hammond doing clinton
chevy chase doing gerald ford
yeah because he didn't try and look like
him he didn't try and sound like him
he just he just made him seem kind of
dumb because he was a very
ordinary average president and that's
what made it so hysterical
the thing that offends me most about the
late night writing over the last four
years
is it has been so unimaginative and it
has been the same joke
rewritten and delivered with the same
contempt
in the same way and there have been no
boundaries that have been
pushed here and that's why uh for a lot
of these shows people have moved on to
other content
people are more excited about what they
can binge watch on netflix
than they are about you know what
colbert said last night because most
people
just don't care because they have
rendered themselves irrelevant
by this redundancy in their humor
and i think it's it's going to be very
bad news for organizations not just late
night
but new york times digital and msnbc and
other places
that have seen their ratings and
subscribership quadruple during the
trump era it could implode so what is
their answer for that going to be
well as bad as late night tv is
it's still funnier than ben stiller
would you agree
still funnier than ben stiller who would
want to see ben stiller
no ben stiller is the least funny person
alive right
right what's he even doing now i don't
even know is he still in the
entertainment industry i don't know i
haven't seen him in a long time
i i i mean i've heard ben stiller is
still around is he doing infomercials
uh maybe like on rotation first
mortgages actually yeah he's doing
reverse
yes exactly